مرحبًا بكم مرة أخرى في الفيديو ، اسمه
نانا ، ربما يكون التجاور هو
الأكثر تناقضًا بين المقاطع ، كانت
نادين مؤثرة طموحة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تنشر عن حياتها غالبًا ما
يظهر
شقيقها الأصغر جود وأختي
والمقطع الذي تم نشره  لقد
انتشر كل هذا فيروسي ،
ماذا تتوقع مني أن أقوم
بإصلاحه ، أنا فقط 10 سنوات.
مجرد طفلة هي
مجرد طفلة ولكن في نفس الوقت
لم تعد تستمتع بها
[موسيقى]
لم أكن أضحك لأنه كان مضحكًا
كنت أضحك لأنني كنت أحاول
إبقاء أخي هادئًا
أعتقد أنني أحبك  أنا أيضًا ، لقد عدنا
مرة أخرى إلى
هنا وهذه هي كل الأشياء التي حصلنا عليها
للمدرسة ،
هذا ما كان يجب أن يكونوا
مستعدين له
بدلاً من ذلك ، هذه حقيبتي في حالة
حدوث أي شيء
أو انفجار منزلنا ، لا
يهمني حقًا  حول
أي من هذه الأشياء في الحقيبة مثل
قلت إنني أهتم بالعائلة ، فأنا أهتم بالآخرين
، وعندما يحدث الانفجار ،
نتسكع جميعًا في هذه الغرفة ، من الأفضل
أن نموت
جميعًا معًا ، هذا هو المكان الذي
يوجد فيه الانفجار ،
هناك سيارة
إسعاف وأعتقد أن هذا  منزل
على
الشاطئ بالطبع تشعر نادين بالخوف
وتقول والدتها إنها تخفي خوفها على
أخيها البطاطا
هذا مثل الإفطار والعشاء
[ضحك]
والدة نادين تراقب عائلتها كما لو
كانت تستمتع بهدوء بضحك
الأجيال الشابة
لأن الضحك هو أثمن في
مثل هذه الأوقات
عندما تعلم أنه حتى لو كنت مجرد طفل
يمكن أن ينتهي في أي لحظة أروى دامون
سيينا